bonjour à toutes et à tous merci d'être
là pour cette dernière journée de notre
université de rentrée le temps file donc
on va aller très très vite je suis
accompagnée de trois hommes dont les
voix sont incontournables et sont
reconnaissables parmi toutes mais avant
de laisser la parole
avant de leur laisser la parole je vous
propose d'écouter le témoignage vidéo de
la chef de la démocratie biélorus et
opposante à la dictature de Luc à chenko
cette blenna tyranovkaïa
[Musique]
ce premier témoignage nous démontre à
quel point la démocratie est attaquée de
toutes parts dans le monde et à quel
point certaines et certains se battent
justement comme nous pour la défendre et
nous avons sur cette scène trois hommes
qui justement sont des défenseurs de la
démocratie de la liberté de la paix ils
vont nous livrer leur éclairage sur une
situation mondiale très difficile où les
vents contraires menacent justement
c'est fondamentaux qui nous sont chers
je vais tout d'abord donner la parole à
mon voisin de droite président de la
commission des affaires étrangères à
l'Assemblée nationale député des
Hauts-de-Seine pour justement nous
rappeler ce cadre international
déstabilisé mais à quel point il nous
faut continuer d'avancer ensemble
Jean-Louis la parole est à toi
merci merci
chers amis je suis vraiment très heureux
de d'aborder avec vous et avec
mais nos partenaires à cette salle cette
tribune c'est pas une tribune ce salon
aborder les grandes questions de
politique étrangère je suis très heureux
notamment je le dis très rapidement de
saluer à la fois Bernard Guetta parce
que ça fait très longtemps que nous nous
connaissons Bernard et moi j'ai une
admiration sans bornes pour l'action
qu'il amenait comme journaliste au
moment de l'état de siège en Pologne
tu allais rendre disait du duc de
Richelieu et que c'était l'homme de
France qui connaissait le mieux la
Crimée Bernard Guetta c'est l'homme de
France qui connaît le mieux la Pologne
et comme la Pologne est un élément
essentiel pour dans la crise européenne
que nous vivons en vérité je crois que
c'est vraiment très important et Bernard
non seulement a été l'homme de cette
solidarité avec Solidarnosc mais il a
été il est il a été constamment on a
toujours partagé une même fois
européenne et de nous nous retrouvons
chaque fois avec plaisir quant à
Jean-Yves évidemment
Jean-Yves de c'est une c'est presque une
rencontre de de malfaiteur qui se
retrouvent
reconstitution le ligue 10 août ça a été
je voudrais vous le dire ça a été très
très grand très très grand bonheur pour
le le membre aux côtés de Marielle puis
le président de la commission des
affaires étrangères d'avoir ce dialogue
permanent régulier confiant amical avec
Jean-yves letoyan dont nous partageons
là aussi on partage les mêmes
convictions européennes on partage le
même souci de l'humanisme on a porté
ensemble cette loi qui avait été conçue
initialement par par Marielle sur l'aide
au développement nous l'avons porté
ensemble avec succès et et c'est un
bonheur pour moi que de le retrouver je
voulais dire ça j'ai un peu mangé mon
temps de parole avec ça je suis désolé
mais c'était quand même important oui
vous avez raison les applaudir ce sont
ce sont à la fois de grands témoins et
de grands acteurs
alors maintenant on m'a demandé de
d'ouvrir en 5 minutes c'est un peu comme
ce qu'on a demandé hier à talx on a
d'ailleurs très bien tiré présenter les
problèmes de l'éducation nationale en 5
minutes il s'en est assez bien tiré moi
je mentirais moins bien mais de faire
une sorte d'introduction sur la
situation internationale telle que de la
voyons je me reviens spontanément à
l'esprit une phrase du général de Gaulle
que je citais hier quand on évoquait les
perspectives des communications
mon cher est vieux pays nous voici à
nouveau dans l'épreuve et effectivement
ce que nous vivons actuellement c'est
pas le dimanche de Pâques c'est plutôt
le vendredi saint de la de la diplomatie
ou que nous tournions nos têtes nous
sommes confrontés à des problèmes
terribles
Jean-Yves Le Drian vous parlera je pense
du Liban puisqu'il a une mission
exceptionnellement importante et et
exceptionnel et importante qu'il assume
pour la demande du Président de la
République
simplement de contribuer à la solution
d'un problème insoluble tout à fait
simple il vous en parlera mais nous
avons nous sommes partout à dans une
situation très tendue
l'Arménie j'en dirai j'en dirai un mot
tout à l'heure le problème n'est pas là
celui du haut Karaba simplement le
Karaba c'est le problème des
des populations dont il faut assurer la
vie la survie l'intégration l'adaptation
mais le problème fondamental c'est celui
de l'Arménie qui est menacé dans sa
souveraineté et sa sécurité nous avons
le problème de l'Ukraine on a vu on a
écouté à l'instant ce que dit notre
grande amie qui combat pour la liberté
aux côtés des Biélorusses l'Ukraine nous
ne devons pas nous ne devons pas me lire
nous sommes dans ce moment très grave de
relative équilibre entre les forces et
et nous savons qu'il n'y aura pas de
paix
satisfaisante honorable pour les
Ukrainiens s'ils ne marquent pas
décisivement des points sur le plan
militaire et c'est évidemment le moment
où on voit ici et là notamment aux
États-Unis mais partout les opinions
publiques facilés ce se dissoutte elles
sont toujours pro ukrainiennes là il ne
faut pas me lire c'est le moment où nous
devons nous mobiliser sur les Ukrainiens
sont en droit d'attendre que nous les
aidions à faire la différence ça
implique des choix ça implique des
sacrifices mais il faut le faire sur sur
l'Afrique
une très bonne interview je sais pas si
tu l'as lu Jean-Yves du président de la
mauritanisme atteint dans
le Figaro je crois enfin je sais pas
pourquoi
qui est vraiment assez remarquable et
qui montre bien je crois propose très
bien le problème nous nous n'avons pas à
rougir de ce que nous faisons en Afrique
nous sommes arrivés pour aider des
démocraties à survivre il y a eu tout un
ensemble de péripéties du d'ailleurs
selon les pays à des causes très
diverses qui font que à un moment un
certain nombre d'acteurs ont intérêt à
nous présenter comme des affaires de
nous des boucs émissaires et à se
présenter comme des victimes la réalité
n'est pas celle-là la réalité c'est que
nous sommes là pour aider si on nous
demande si on n'a pas besoin de nous
nous partons c'est très clair mais la
vérité c'est que le combat que nous
menons et que et qui est celui des
démocrate en Afrique reste vigilant
Tombouctou et Gao sont semble-t-il aux
mains des islamistes au maïs au Mali
c'est extrêmement grave donc il faut
bien se dire que nous n'avons pas à
rougir de ce que nous avons fait nous
n'avons rien fait de et nous serons
présents avec nos amis sous les formes
qu'ils voudront dans les conditions
qu'ils voudront en Afrique parce que le
lien entre l'Afrique et l'Europe et
entre l'Afrique et la France sont des
liens sont des liens permanents qui
doivent être entretenus et maintenues
donc il faut surmonter passer ces
mauvaises épisodes surtout ne pas faire
de provocation mais savoir que l'avenir
restera celui d'une relation forte entre
les Africains et nous je pourrais je
pourrais multiplier
je pourrais multiplier les exemples je
ne le ferai pas parce que ma voisine
sera ma présidente serait furieuse je
dirais simplement en conclusion que nous
devons faire preuve comme nous l'avons
toujours fait notamment dans notre
mouvement mais d'une façon générale la
majorité et la France nous devons faire
preuve des trois qualités qui sont
absolument essentielles d'abord la
fidélité aux valeurs l'idée que on
puisse faire une diplomatie sur de
simples rapports de force sans référence
aux valeurs sans être guidé par les
valeurs c'est une idée totalement
illusoire Max Weber l'avait dit grand
philosophe de des relations
internationales qui avaient inspiré
rémoison avait dit il n'y a rien de plus
saut de plus médiocre qu'une politique
de puissance la politique étrangère est
et restera une tension permanente entre
des rapports de force difficile et une
exigence éthique nous défendons les
valeurs les valeurs de l'Europe les
valeurs que nous avons apportées au
monde nous n'avons pas rougir de ces
valeurs et nous avons à nous battre pour
elle sachons être fidèle à notre idéal
sans être naïf c'est le premier point
deuxième banc nous devons être je crois
nous devons être habiles nous devons
être prudents nous devons savoir que
nous vivons une révolution copernicienne
nous ne sommes pas le centre du monde
comme nous l'étions au 18e siècle sous
Louis XIV au 18e siècle non nous sommes
une puissance avec des moyens des moyens
moraux des moyens matériels des moyens
monétaires des moyens technologiques un
peuple actif entreprenant mais nous
sommes un peuple de 65 millions
d'habitants dans un univers qui est très
très largement en train de se recentre
se réorganiser à partir de pays neufs de
pays qui avaient été humiliés dans le
passé donc nous comptons nous comptons
mais nous comptons pour pour notre part
ça ça nous demande un exercice qui n'est
pas l'exercice le plus auquel nous
sommes le plus familiarisé qui est un
exercice d'humilité mais cette humilité
elle est nécessaire et elle ne nous
dispense absolument pas d'être présent
et le troisième message que je voudrais
dire c'est que surtout quand ça ne va
pas bien et en ce moment la situation
internationale est vraiment très dure
nous devons être déterminés le général
de Gaulle était déterminé en 40 alors
que tout allait mal là heureusement nous
n'en sommes pas la loin de là mais nous
devons faire preuve de détermination
c'est maintenant que tout se révèlera
que tout se jouera et notamment nous
devons être déterminés à utiliser à
sauver le grand instrument dont nous
disposons qui est l'union européenne
nous devons savoir qu'il n'y aura pas
d'avenir pour nos valeurs nos intérêts
nos idées ce que nous sommes ce que nous
représentons dans le monde si l'Europe
n'est pas unie or l'Europe est en crise
l'Europe est menacée dans un certain
nombre de de notamment dans ces
principes institutions
européennes nous devons y aller sous
notre drapeau nous devons y aller avec
nos convictions et nous devons aller
avec l'idée que nous devons porter
auprès de mes parts de nos partenaires
que de toute manière nos intérêts à tous
pas les intérêts de la France les
intérêts de l'Allemagne de l'Italie de
la Pologne de l'Europe centrale de
l'Espagne nos intérêts à tous c'est
d'agir ensemble et solidairement il faut
redonner à l'Union européenne sa
capacité d'unité de mobilisation
d'actions c'est à ce prix que nous
sortirons sans doute et plus que sans
doute que nous sortirons certainement si
nous réussissons à passer cet obstacle
des élections européennes dans de bonnes
conditions c'est à ce prix que nous
réussirons à exister au 21ème siècle
donc soyons
soyons humbles soyons résolus soyons
unis et soyons conscients que nous
défendons quelque chose un trésor absolu
qui est le trésor de nos valeurs et de
nos principes c'est ainsi que nous
serons entendus
merci beaucoup
Jean-Louis tu l'as dit dans ton
introduction tu as présenté notamment
Bernard Guetta avec des mots qui
effectivement le caractérise évidemment
tu nous as appelé à ne pas me lire tu as
expliciter les choses c'est exactement
ce qui fait au Parlement européen donc
je suis très heureuse de donner la
parole à mon collègue Bernard Guetta
merci à vous tous de m'avoir invité car
je suis toujours très heureux de me
retrouver avec mes amis du MoDem et
particulièrement à Guidel merci
évidemment de ces mots beaucoup trop
gentils et
sachez que cette amitié qui nous unit
depuis 40 ans et vraiment très profonde
parce qu'elle est fondée sur une
convergence mais quasi constante quasi
constante d'idées de réflexion de
réaction quant à mon voisin immédiat
juste un mot je viens de lui dédicacer
un bouquin au meilleur des ministres et
tout est dit et tout est dit
[Applaudissements]
alors maintenant
je réagissais je pensais en voyant cette
interview c'est une interview de madame
tyranovskaïa
je me disais mais finalement elle
incarne la rupture que nous vivons parce
que entre nous soit dit j'espère qu'il
n'y a pas de Bélarus dans la salle mais
le B la Russe était vraiment
un morceau de la Russie un cousin si on
veut mais les Bélarus ne se voyaient pas
autrement qu'appartenant à l'espace
russe à une communauté intellectuelle
culturelle politique je vois quelqu'un
qui hoche un peu la tête oui bien sûr on
peut contester ça on peut mais
fondamentalement si quand même et bien
aujourd'hui le Belarus
se sent appartenir à un autre espace et
très profondément et c'est la même chose
pour l'Ukraine et c'est la même chose
pour l'Ukraine mais maintenant portons
nos regards
un peu sur d'autres sur d'autres
continents partout nous vivons un moment
de rupture absolue
la première rupture c'est que depuis
cinq siècles depuis la Renaissance
l'Occident dont nous faisons partie
dominer le monde à tout point de vue pas
seulement militairement pas seulement
économiquement et industriellement mais
aussi fondamentalement
culturellement bien écoutez aujourd'hui
d'autres puissances se sont affirmées et
quelle puissance nous entendons tous les
jours que les démocraties reculent au
profit des dictatures je ne dirais pas
cela parce que écoutez souvenons-nous du
monde pendant la guerre froide
l'Amérique latine était un continent de
dictatures militaire l'Afrique était à
quelques exceptions près bien rares
incontinent de dictatures l'Asie était
incontinent de dictatures et ne parlons
pas évidemment de l'Europe centrale et
de l'Union soviétique donc que ce n'est
pas une question ce n'est pas une
question de nombre ce n'est pas cela les
deux grands changements c'est que des
dictatures
sont devenus
d'immenses puissants démographique
économique industrielle et militaire et
que le rapport de force entre les
démocraties et les dictatures à en ce
sens totalement évolué et
malheureusement en défaveur de la
démocratie
changement
c'est que y compris sous Staline qui se
vantait d'avoir donné à l'Union
soviétique la Constitution la plus
démocratique du monde effectivement
d'ailleurs sur le papier c'était
probablement une constitution
extrêmement déboratiques mais nous
savons bien la différence entre le
papier et le goulag mais à cette époque
là à cette époque là
les dictatures rendaient hommage à la
démocratie et l'hypocrisie était
évidemment un hommage que le vice
rendait à la vertu de nos jours les
dictatures nous disent et disent au
monde entier
nous sommes bien plus forts bien plus
efficace bien plus vertueux que vous les
démocraties
décadentes inévicales et votre aide dans
le vice et votre est dans le vice
écouter ce que Martel monsieur Orban est
là au sein même de l'Union européenne
les actuels dirigeants polonais hélas au
sein même de l'Union européenne mais
surtout surtout évidemment monsieur
Poutine monsieur Poutine alors
aujourd'hui nous avons un défi à relever
qui est un défi mais absolument
colossale et il est bien évident
et la gentame ce que nous aurons à dire
pendant la campagne électorale pour les
européennes il est bien évident que même
des pays aussi puissants à tout point de
vue que l'Allemagne ou la France ne
peuvent pas relever ce défi seul il nous
faut là apprendre l'humilité à laquelle
tu viens de nous appeler bien sûr que
nous ne pouvons pas la France vient de
le voir en Afrique nous le savions mais
nous l'avons éprouvé ce qui est
différent nous ne pouvons pas relever
seul
la tenté il y a un peu plus d'un an le
défi chinois mais l'Allemagne a vite
renoncé l'Allemagne se retourne y
compris sur la question de ces
exportations vers la Chine vers l'Union
européenne
alors quand nous entendons
quand nous péniblement absolument quand
nous entendrons et nous les entendons
déjà des eurosceptiques il en reste il
en reste de moins en moins d'ailleurs
parce que les sondages montrent bien que
nos opinions publiques pas seulement en
France dans tous les pays de l'Union
comprennent de plus en plus
majoritairement la nécessité absolue de
l'unité européenne et bien quand nous
entendrons des eurosceptiques ou
des europhobes
déguisés
en européen monsieur Bardella et
d'autres
quand nous les enterons
attaquer l'Union européenne il y a une
seule chose à leur répondre est-ce que
vous voulez
que nous soyons pris en sandwich écrasé
brisés marginalisés par les deux
puissances qui domineront
le 21e siècle la Chine et les États-Unis
est-ce que vous voulez que nous serions
sous une influence politique et
économique de la Chine et ce que vous
voulez que nous soyons dépendants
entièrement des États-Unis pour échapper
à cette puissance chinoise et la soudain
99% de nos concitoyens français et du
reste de l'Union disent non évidemment
parce que personne ne rêverait de vivre
sous la domination de la Chine et
personne ne veut vivre
dans la dépendance
des États-Unis
de plus en plus désireux de réaffirmer
leur puissance et leur primauté la
solution
que nous nous en réjouissons ou pas nous
nous en réjouissons ici d'autres ne sont
réjouissent pas mais quel que soit les
points de départ la solution
obligatoire et notre unité et donc
l'Union européenne
cette bataille il va falloir la mener
parce que nous devrons dire dans la
campagne que dans les 5 années qui
viennent de s'écouler
l'Union a commencé à s'affirmer en union
politique c'est le troisième moment où
le troisième chapitre de son histoire il
y a eu le marché commun il y a eu la
menée unique aujourd'hui et bien
aujourd'hui ce sont les premiers pas
d'une défense commune d'une politique
étrangère d'emprunts communs de
politiques industrielles communes je dis
bien les premiers et pas mais il y a
encore une poignée d'années ces mots
défenses communes politiques
industrielle comme une empreinte en
parlons même pas était totalement tabou
dans l'Union européenne et bien
aujourd'hui ils sont acceptés même si il
y a des divergences bien naturelles par
parenthèses sur ce que devrait être les
politiques comme industriels communes la
défense commune etc et bien aujourd'hui
nous devons organiser
notre union en puissance politique et je
m'arrête là car j'ai déjà été trop long
merci beaucoup Bernard il est ici chez
lui
il a été maire de Lorient il a été
président de la Région Bretagne ministre
de la Défense ministre de l'affaire
étrangères et de l'Europe merci beaucoup
Jean-Yves Le Drian vous a été rappelé
par Jean-Louis Bourlon je vous avais
maintenant la difficulté de être le
représentant pour la France pour le
Liban et votre éclairage va être
extrêmement important pour nous tous je
vous laisse la parole merci merci
beaucoup Marie-Pierre
et je veux je vous redis tout le plaisir
que j'ai d'être ici Guidel avec mon
épouse on vient en voisin parce que nous
avons vécu nous avons habité pendant une
dizaine d'années à 200 mètres d'ici mais
aussi on vient pour l'amitié l'amitié
avec Bernard et Jean-Louis bourlange et
je dois leur dire que
nos conversations me manquent
Alain et à l'autre dont nous avons
échangé essayer d'agir ensemble au cours
des dernières années et puis je suis
très heureux d'être ici avec les
militants de du modèle le modèle qui a
en Bretagne une histoire une place très
importante et qui entoure bien le garder
si j'ai bien compris
quelques mots sur sur le Liban puisque
vous m'y inciter et que je sais
l'importance que représente le Liban
pour votre formation politique et votre
histoire sans doute
cette formation politique est-elle celle
qui est le plus dans le passé était
mobilisé sur la question libanaise
le président de la République m'a confié
une mission
en me demandant pas de
d'obligatoirement d'avoir des résultats
une mission d'objectif peut-être de
résultat si possible dans une situation
extrêmement compliquée
ce pays est en train de mourir pour dire
les choses très clairement telles que je
les vois j'ai eu l'occasion de dire à un
moment donné que le Liban c'était le
Titanic sans l'orchestre c'est le cas
il n'y a plus de président de la
République depuis un an
il n'y a plus de Premier ministre
puisqu'il est démissionnaire et qui ne
fait que régler les affaires courantes
depuis 18 mois
le Parlement ne se réunit plus
le
l'ancien gouverneur de la Banque
centrale il y a encore quelques semaines
et sous mandat d'arrêt international
et pendant ce temps-là
la situation économique du Liban se
détériore
inflation à 200%
les fonds de réserve de la banque
libanaise sont quasiment asséchés dans
peu de temps ce pays mettra la clé sous
la porte si je peux me permettre
l'expression on ne peut pas retirer
d'argent évidemment dans les banques il
y a une forme de dollarisation du pays
par la pénétration du cash tout
simplement les jeunes quittent le pays
chômage de 50% pour la population des
jeunes de moins de 20 ans il quitte le
pays et des mouvements de par milliers
de Libanais se produisent alors que dans
le même temps la situation sécuritaire
interne comment ça se dégrader d'une
part par des affrontements dans les
camps palestiniens d'autre part par des
incidents entre communautés parfois
incident violent avec des morts
récemment puis en même temps ça nous
amène une autre question des mouvements
de Syriens vers le Liban
à un niveau très important puisque c'est
2500 à 2000 jeunes syriens par jour
par jour
que l'armée libanaise qui est le seul le
seul la seule solidité qui existe
aujourd'hui essaye de tant mieux que mal
de contenir parce que c'est rien Vienne
au Liban et ensuite viennent prendre le
bateau à Tripoli ou ailleurs pour
essayer de rejoindre l'Europe bref une
situation qui devient extrêmement
dramatique et face à cela une classe
politique qui est dans le déni et qui
continue ses jeux internes
de manière absolument inacceptable je le
dis ici même si et j'espère être entendu
relayer par une presse qui invente des
scénarios parce que
lorsqu'il n'y a pas de d'événement
nouveau ils ont produisent eux-mêmes qui
aboutissent à ce que ce Liban vit dans
une espèce de schizophrénie permanente
et je ne vois difficilement aujourd'hui
les voies de sortie sauf si il y a un
sursaut il y a capacité d'insurceau
parce qu'il y a une population civile
extrêmement active extrêmement tonique
très éduqué formé en grande partie par
des écoles françaises qui ne veut pas en
rester là qui s'est manifesté en 2019
par des grands mouvements de rue que
vous avez connus mais qui maintenant
était une espèce de fatalisme qui
s'empare des populations civiles après
l'explosion du port de Beyrouth tout
cela aboutit à une espèce d'impuissance
partagée
que je constate mais qui pourrait se
réveiller s'il y avait une dynamique
quelle est la dynamique possible
elle elle est en gros celle-ci pour ma
part
il faut essayer de dépasser un
fonctionnement du Parlement libanais qui
est très pervers que je ne
conseille pas pour le Parlement français
et vous allez comprendre pourquoi
pour qu'il y ait une élection d'un
président de la République puisque c'est
le Parlement libanais qui doit voter ce
qui différencent de la France et le
Parlement libanais qui vote pour le
président de la République il faut qu'il
y ait les deux tiers de présent pour
voter
et donc comme aujourd'hui il y a deux
candidats potentiels regroupant chacun
des forces diverses l'un soutenu un peu
pariste le hezbollas en particulier mais
pas uniquement avec aussi une partie
chrétienne mais aussi une petite partie
sunnite et de l'autre côté un autre
candidat soutenu plus par les forces
maronites mais pas uniquement avec aussi
un peu de sunnites c'est de là ne
veulent pas bouger ces deux forces là ne
veulent pas bouger et lorsque on sent
que l'un peut gagner et bien à ce
moment-là le tiers qui représente les
autres sortes de la salle et il peut pas
y avoir de vote
et ça peut durer des mois
et ils sont bloqués et aujourd'hui
aucune réforme n'est possible dans ce
pays malgré les injonctions du faux
monétaire international et de la
communauté internationale parce que ce
pays aussi emprunt de corruption chacun
ayant ses prébendes et ses capacités de
redistribution on reste bloqué et pour
aboutir à ce que par fatigue à un moment
donné l'un des deux lâches il faut donc
une troisième solution il y a des
candidatures possibles de consensus
partiel sur des grands objectifs pour
sortir le Liban de l'impasse chacun le
sait personne ne le veut et donc notre
mission la mienne c'est d'essayer de
faire en sorte que on dépasse le clivage
actuel pour aboutir à une candidature
qui soit la plus large possible parce
que sans une candidature large on ne
pourra pas mener les réformes
indispensables sinon chers amis il y
aura plus de Liban tout simplement il
n'y aura plus de Liban et les Libanais
sont convaincus qui sont au centre du
monde la classe politique libanaise est
convaincue qui sont le centre du monde
ce qu'ils ne sont plus personne ne
s'intéresse plus à eux sauf la France et
eux pensent que tout le monde
s'intéresse à eux donc il faut ce qu'ils
se rendent compte que désormais la
responsabilité d'entre leurs mains une
des mes tâches a été de décider de
mobiliser l'Arabie saoudite le Qatar les
gîte les États-Unis à la nécessité de
trouver une sortie pour le Liban parce
que même si dans cette région du monde
on en parlera peut-être tout à l'heure
tout change très vite il ne faudrait pas
qu'il reste au bout là un abcès purulent
qui risque ensuite d'entraîner du
terrorisme ou d'autres manifestations de
ce type si d'aventure l'état n'existe
plus il n'existe presque plus il y a
encore une chance de survie et ce à quoi
j'essaye de
m'engager pour essayer de trouver une
une bonne sortie essayons d'éviter le
bavardage les Libanais sur des habitudes
du bavardage ils le font facilement au
Liban eux-mêmes ou par presse interposés
ils le font aussi en France mais là il y
a une nécessité urgente c'est de
renoncer aux affrontements du moment
pour essayer de trouver une sortie qui
soit qui permet au Liban de continuer à
vivre voilà ce que je voulais dire
rapidement sur le Liban si à un moment
donné on y arrive pas et bien les
Libanais seront devant leur propre
responsabilités on aura tout fait pour
les aider on ne peut pas aider des gens
qui ne veulent pas être aidés voilà tout
simplement
je vais rajouter
mais c'est quand même très préoccupant
je voudrais rajouter un point par
rapport au débat général pour vous dire
que ma conviction c'est que l'année 2024
est une année de tous les dangers
parce qu'il y a beaucoup d'élections
européennes on va en parler on a déjà
parlé je pense que tout à l'heure tiré
breton parla et son majeurs à la fois
pour nous en France mais aussi pour nous
en Europe mais aussi les élections
Russie
il y a aussi les élections Ukraine comme
par hasard les élections Russie les
élections en Ukraine et les élections
Grande-Bretagne et puis surtout les
élections aux États-Unis et il y en a un
qui attend avec impatience les résultats
des élections américaines c'est Poutine
ce qui me fait dire d'ailleurs que rien
ne bougera de manière
significative d'ici ce moment-là et il y
a tout à craindre de l'élection
américaine quand on voit à la fois les
sondages les propos les durcissements
que l'on peut lire de la part du
candidat Trump potentiel alors que la
présidence bayden et je trouve tout à
fait honorable dans ces engagements et
dans ses choix il n'empêche que cette
élection américaine sera déterminante
elle interviendra après d'autres
élections mais cela signifie une très
grande vigilance de notre part est une
certaine manière une inquiétude si je
peux encore avoir une minute pour
rappeler des souvenirs mais il faut
toujours embêtant quand on a des anciens
ministres parce qu'ils parlent de leur
souvenir beaucoup plus que souvent que
l'actualité il n'empêche que
j'étais mise à faire étrangères pendant
les quatre années de Trump
et j'ai vu
constater le forme de désintérêt
progressif des États-Unis à l'égard de
l'Europe y compris ce qui se pouvait se
passer en Ukraine même si c'était
heureusement postérieur
au mandat de Trump et j'ai vu aussi des
interrogations et des doutes sur
l'alliance
Atlantique quand le président Macron
évoquait l'amor cérébrale il n'avait pas
tort j'ai vu aussi des tentations de
retrait de la part des États-Unis à
l'égard de notre propre sécurité et je
vois aussi je lis aussi que le président
Trump dit moi je règle à faire
ukrainienne en une journée il suffit de
me donner les moyens de le faire lorsque
j'arriverai aux affaires et on imagine
de quelle manière donc c'est une année
2024 extrêmement grave qui se présente
et qui nécessitera une forme
mobilisation et j'espère une affirmation
très forte de notre conception
européenne merci
merci beaucoup Jean-Yves parce que tu as
effectivement dans cette salle tous ceux
qui seront pleinement mobilisés
justement l'année prochaine pour
affirmer haut et fort ces convictions et
répondre à tout les perspectives que
vous avez dressé les uns les autres
Jean-Louis je me retourne vers toi je
pense qu'il serait important que tu
puisses comme tu l'as dit tout à l'heure
rappeler à quel point la situation au
carabach est difficile et à quel point
nous devons justement pleinement nous
mobiliser
oui mais merci merci
j'étais en Arménie
la semaine qui a précédé
l'invasion je suis rentré le samedi
l'invasion a eu lieu le lundi j'ai
rencontré effectivement les différents
responsables à commencer
par le Premier ministre monsieur
pachinian
d'abord le sentiment
en tant que Français je le dis parce que
presque les seuls en tout cas les plus
engagés au service de leur souveraineté
et de l'intégrité de leur territoire
quand on se promène on sait pas toujours
le cas quand on se promène avec la
voiture de l'ambassadeur et le fanion
tricolore on est applaudit
quand on va dans la mission on
accompagne la mission de l'Union
européenne et je sais pourtant que
l'Union européenne et est un peu et est
un peu hésitante dans cette affaire mais
on sait que cette mission a été demandé
par la France moi-même d'ailleurs il
savait ils étaient très conscient que
j'avais
interpellé madame Colonna sur ce sujet
qui avait répondu très positivement pour
qu'on relance cette mission
d'observation et bien quand on se
promène dans les campagnes d'Arménie
avec le drapeau de l'Union européenne on
dit tout de suite klaxonné par en signe
de solidarité il y a un sentiment de
désespérance un sentiment de d'abandon
qui caractérise les Arméniens dont nous
sommes exclus nous sommes ceux qui
restent près d'eux et nous devons
évidemment être fidèles à ce mandat qu'
automatiquement une nous donne j'ai je
suis allé
dans une commune jumelée avec la ville
de clamart dont je suis le député et
c'était absolument émouvant j'ai été
accueilli évidemment avec l'orchestre
qui chantait à tue-tête
Aznavour la vie de bohème etc la bohème
et
tous ses enfants on voyait tous ses
enfants avec ses petits drapeaux il y
avait une école de la Francophonie tout
cela des enfants de 8 ans 10 ans 12 ans
dont on se disait que
ils étaient dans la ferveur dans la
gentillesse la douceur et qu'ils étaient
promis vraiment à une existence très
très difficile pour maintenir leur pays
donc c'est quelque chose de très
profondément profondément émouvant que
nous que nous ressentons là-bas alors
sur le je serai bref
assez clair et assez tragiquement simple
le problème n'est pas celui du haut
Karba le problème duo carambar il était
réglé tragiquement réglé désespérément
réglé avant l'agression à l'if possédé
tous les moyens militaires et
diplomatique d'imposer sa loi dans ce
territoire et nous savons le degré de
hostilité de haine de de violence entre
les Arméniens et les et les ACI et il y
avait donc un risque absolument énorme
il avait bloqué le corridor de la Chine
il l'avait fait non pas
pour maintenir les populations du
haut-karaba dans leur dans leur enclave
mais pour leur rendre la vie impossible
dans cet enclave et le moment venu
moment où libérer
le corridor avec une en nombre ou une
menace une menace génocidaire clairement
la menace de la destruction physique des
populations qui provoqueraient un exode
massif exode qui s'est produit l'aspect
dernière dans les conditions qu'on a vu
à travers toutes ces images qui
n'étaient pas sans nous rappeler les
images de l'exode de 1940 pour nous donc
on a mais c'était réglé pachinian
avait été élu en disant qu'il ne
referait pas la guerre et il avait
raison il ne referait pas la guerre à
l'Azerbaïdjan parce qu'il l'aurait perdu
qu'il aurait naufragé son pays que le il
n'y avait aucun moyen d'action pour lui
et d'ailleurs si la gagner les élections
c'est pour deux raisons c'est d'abord
parce que les Arméniens étaient
conscients qui ne pourraient pas
s'engager dans une nouvelle guerre pour
l'eau Caraba et deuxièmement qu'ils
étaient aussi très désireux de maintenir
ce pouvoir poste soviétique qui tournait
le dos à la dictature et à la corruption
des amis de la Russie en Arménie donc
dans le parmi les leaders qui est
successeurs de l'empire soviétique ou
des alliés et bien évidemment pachilla
ne fait partie comme comme elle inscrit
comme la présidente moldave de ceux qui
luttent contre la corruption et qui
défendent la démocratie simplement pour
lui la situation est beaucoup plus
difficile parce que l'Occident n'est pas
solidaire n'a pas été jusqu'à présent
solidaire de l'Arménie c'est ça le
problème le problème fondamental le
Karaba c'est tragiquement réglé nous
avons de voir vis-à-vis des populations
moi
j'ai dit l'autre jour à France Inter
chez Madame synthèse qui m'avait
Fabienne synthèse qui m'interrogeait
j'ai dit que on devait faire trois
choses on devait d'abord permettre à
l'Arménie d'accéder à la facilité
européenne pour la paix c'est quelque
chose d'important c'est un moyen de
donner des armes à l'Arménie en les
faisant payer par l'Union européenne
pour être assez sommaire Borel avait
refusé ça il y a quelques semaines il a
eu tort à mon avis j'aime beaucoup Borel
je crois que c'est un homme très très
intelligent et très bien insensé mais là
il a fait preuve d'une timidité
excessive les Espagnols se méfient un
peu de l'Arménie se méfier du
haut-karaba parce que tout ce qui
ressemble à la Catalogne des inquiets et
et mais enfin il y a cette première
cette première chose deuxièmement je
crois que l'Union européenne devrait à
l'appel de la France faire un véritable
plan
un véritable plan non pas simplement
humanitaire mais un plan d'intégration
de des populations qui sont pas très
nombreuses il y a pas 120 000 puis il y
avait pas 120 000 personnes au Kaaba
sont des chiffres assez gonflés
c'est gonflé notamment par laserbeille
Jean qui comme ça dit s'il y en a que
50000 60000 qui 80000 qui s'en vont ça
veut dire qu'il en reste c'est pas vrai
il y a à peu près 80 000 il y avait à
peu près 80 000 Arméniens au Caraba il y
en a il y en avait il y a quelque chose
déjà 50000 qui étaient parvenus en
Arménie donc c'est une c'est une un
nettoyage ethnique presque complet qui
se réalise et nous devons les aider nous
devons les aider nous devons faire un
plan et l'Union européenne qui n'a pas
été brillante jusqu'à présent malgré les
appels de la France l'Union européenne
se doit de se de se mobiliser sur cette
affaire et
et nous devons nous-mêmes d'ailleurs
donné des armes dans de vendre des armes
dans des conditions à définir avec la
discrétion qui s'impose dans ce genre de
choses je crois que là il y a vraiment
quelque chose de de très important à
conduire
au-delà de ça je pense que il faut bien
il faut bien comprendre que le
l'Arménie menacé pourquoi
les Turcs se fichent complètement du
haut Karaba ils ont laissé à l'IEF le
prendre en main parce que ça fait
plaisir à alief mais c'est un cul-de-sac
en revanche les Turcs sont passionnément
engagés sur l'institution de la
continuité territoriale entre leur
territoire et jusqu'à la mer Caspienne
c'est le grand mythe envers Pacha etc
vers le Touran et ça ça implique mettre
en cause la souveraineté et l'intégrité
du territoire arménien en reliant d'une
manière ou d'une autre les deux les deux
passages les deux
parties de l'Azerbaïdjan et ça il faut
absolument s'y opposer la seule
puissance qui s'y oppose aujourd'hui et
c'est tragique pour le Liban pour le
Liban lapsus est tragique pour l'Arménie
c'est l'Iran et comme c'est l'Iran les
États-Unis les Européens regardent tout
ça avec avec horreur il considère que
pachinian est protégé par par l'Iran et
là nous avons une situation très précise
dans laquelle pachinian et menacé à la
fois par des manœuvres de
déstabilisation je termine de son
territoire menacé par des manœuvres de
déstabilisation de son territoire
inspiré par les Russes nourrit
évidemment par la revendication et
l'angoisse des réfugiés et en même temps
il n'est pas du tout soutenu par les
puissances
occidentales alors là je crois que
l'Union européenne doit véritablement et
les États-Unis doivent se mobiliser sur
l'intégrité et la souveraineté de
l'Arménie nous avons été tragiquement
pas la France mais les autres nous avons
été tragiquement silencieux sur l'eau
Caraba nous avons le devoir d'être
extrêmement vigilant mobilisé
contraignant actifs pour la préservation
de l'intégrité et de la souveraineté de
l'Arménie c'est un devoir collectif
désordre des Français des Européens et
des Occidentaux
Occident réveille-toi merci beaucoup
merci à tous les trois je salue
l'arrivée de Thierry Breton
malheureusement nous devons justement
libérer la scène merci Monsieur le
Commissaire d'être avec nous merci à
vous tous je crois que justement vous
avez dressé de vrais appels à l'action
vous avez dressé de vraies visions
justement qui nous oblige donc merci à
chacun d'entre vous pour avoir suivi ce
temps des changements
[Applaudissements]